foreign
do squirrels play
I observed a squirrel in my backyard
wrestling a stick and doing little jumps
from a tree trunk back to the stick on
the ground no other squirrel was
involved and it seemed like something it
might be doing just for the fun of it
however I know that I can't make
assumptions about what a behavior might
mean based only my perception how do
animal behaviorists determine the
meaning behind what they observe animals
doing
so especially if you were looking at a
young squirrel
he was playing
mammals need to learn how to be the
adults that they're going to become and
the longer the childhood the more likely
what you're seeing is play uh squirrels
depending on species they have they have
childhoods they have developmental
periods not you know nothing as long as
ours not as long as most the carnivorous
probably
um but they're gonna be playing but
to what degree does play persist in the
adult form well in a in an environment
like a squirrel has assuming this is an
arboreal squirrel rather than a ground
squirrel
the landscape in which that squirrel
lives will change over time precisely
because trees are growing into light
gaps and and
um and you know branches are falling off
and all of this and so they can't just
learn a route learn how to jump across
gaps that exist and that's the only jump
they'll ever have to make and you know
they do the same thing over and over
again so they need to retain plasticity
and play is a form of manifesting of
generating plasticity and you know
learning how to do different things that
maybe you haven't yet been exposed to or
practicing what you haven't exposed to
but aren't yet good at
um I would add so that that works for
play but how do you know when you are
looking at a behavior and you're trying
to understand what it's for it's like
everything else you you know you observe
a behavior like let's say we're talking
about a frog climbing a tree
and you
you hypothesize if the behavior is seen
multiple times so you have a pattern you
hypothesize a possible explanation for
the pattern so basically what you're
trying to explain is why an animal would
a have the features that allow it to
climb a tree right that's a expenditure
in the surface of the pads the
locomotory pattern that allows it to
climb a vertical tree which is difficult
without falling off the risk that it
will fall off and die or land in some
place that it has to work its way out of
right all of those things are reasons
not to climate tree so the fact that the
animal is climbing a tree is a pattern
and then you would create a hypothesis
and the hypothesis might be based on oh
that animal has a uh a tadpole on its
back
right so it may be that it's foraging at
the top of the tree and that it's
carrying a tadpole to keep it out of
trouble right well that hypothesis makes
a prediction which is that when the
animal comes back down the tree it's
still going to have the tadpole on the
back when the animal comes down the tree
and doesn't have the tadpole on the back
then the point is oh maybe it deposited
the tadpole
somewhere
right so you could then pursue that
hypothesis by following an animal and
seeing if it deposited that tadpole
someplace that a tadpole is capable of
uh maturing right so in any case it's
just it's just like that each of the
subsidiary behaviors is a pattern
there's a list of hypotheses that could
explain it
the ideal thing is to come up with an
exhaustive list that at least has every
possible answer somewhere in a unique
category that makes special predictions
and then you follow the predictions to
see which of them are manifest and
sometimes what happens is something you
didn't think of shows up so that you
need a new hypothesis right if it lands
in none of your categories then you
probably missed one and so you need to
go back and go to that stage and figure
out what the what the remainder is
I would say that um when you're walking
into a system a system that's new to you
that you really haven't spent any time
in uh if you if you know that what your
goal is is to try to figure out what
you're seeing and what it means
uh is that first you just spend a lot of
time observing
uh and and
just getting a sense of what all happens
here like what the solution said of all
the possible behaviors is knowing that
the rare things which may be the most
explanatory you may not you may not see
ever um and if you do see it you may see
it on the last day of your study right
like so you it's not going to be a
complete solution set
but then once you start actually um
generating data and you know a lot of
data in animal behavior is not
experimental data but observational data
but observational data that's taken
explicitly and carefully wherein you
have decided in advance what organism
you're going to watch how long you're
going to watch it for how you're going
to code your data so that you're not
biased by like oh look at what that's
happening over there such that you get a
skew in terms you know especially if
you're trying to create like an ethogram
or you know a a Time budget of like how
it would do it because organisms spend
their time
uh if you haven't gone in knowing okay
I'm going to watch these organisms for
this amount of time
um then you're going to be you're going
to be distracted easily distracted by
the fun stuff that may be happening not
among your focal animals
but even when it seems really obvious
and it's hardest to do when it seems
really obvious and most important to do
and it seems really obvious uh you don't
say oh I know what that thing is I'm
just gonna write down and you know the
example
the example that I've used most because
I remember doing it myself was with the
frogs of Madagascar
they are highly convergent as it turns
out with these frogs in the new world
the gender bad is the poison dart frogs
I had also worked on an example of which
Brett was just talking about
um they're highly convergent and the
frogs in the new world the tender batids
have these extended wrestling matches
which I had seen which is you know not
unknown in frogs but certainly most
people who don't think about tropical
frogs don't expect frogs to be doing
this and it's pretty remarkable and so I
had in my head that I might be seeing
these fights between territorial males
but when I went in I didn't I didn't
know no one knew no one in the west and
I believe no one anywhere knew anything
about these frogs are they territorial
are they sexually dimorphic like you
know nothing
so the expectation that I would be
seeing fights was there
but when I started to see what I knew to
be two males jumping on top of each
other and writing them writing each
other around and going belly to belly
against each other and
um running up bamboo at one another and
having one come off and then the next
come off and then the chase continued
it really felt like a fight from the
very beginning and I ended up saying I
have to go back to my
data but you know hundreds of these
things over uh the course of almost a
thousand hours of of uh focal
observations
if I had just started writing down fight
I wouldn't know for sure that that was
what I was looking at and I also would
have no ability to go back and say yes
but what was I encoding us fight early
on so the hard thing and you can't be
totally accurate and one way that people
do this is they take video of everything
but then you have to go back and spend
time with the video so you know you you
create problems for yourself with most
of the solutions you you you create as
well
you write down as much as possible with
as little interpretation as possible
what is actually happening what am I
actually seeing not what do I think it
means and you wait as long as possible
before you add the meaning layer on it
and so you know you're the second part
of your question which Brett was also
answering how do animal behaviors
determine the meaning behind what they
observe animals doing you wait as long
as possible
um to decide to to to lay on top your
interpretation of what uh of what you're
seeing what you think it means and you
do that with you know as as you've seen
more and more okay I've got hypotheses
I'm trying to come I'm trying to create
a complete hypothesis solution set and
then what are the predictions from each
of those et cetera et cetera so this
raises a key question now which I don't
think I've ever heard discussed which is
there has to be a sweet spot about how
much you assume uh yeah and how much you
do not assume so yeah nothing right if
you watch an animal
consume another animal is it safe to say
that it was eating to satisfy its
nutritional and energetic needs totally
right and the answer is it might not be
there can be examples where this isn't
the case but in general the if you chase
everything down you know you'll you know
nothing right you don't even know
frankly if you haven't looked at if you
go and you look at an animal you don't
for sure know that it's a member of the
species that you think it's a member of
you don't know for sure anything I did
this with regard to the frogs uh where I
did I did try to test this but I went in
with the assumption that I know that
some of these frogs vocalize I know that
some of them call given what we know
about the other four or five thousand
species of frogs
I'm going to start with the assumption
that it's only males who call yeah but
I'm going to need to try to figure out
if I you know given that there's very
little sexual amorphism how else am I
going to know unless I see you know a
female depositing an egg
um
you know there's and I didn't do the
sections I didn't I didn't take apart
these frogs
um so that's that's an assumption that
like okay you know what given all the
rest of frogs and given how deep These
Guys these are not basil within frogs
um that's a probably a safe assumption
but I still have to recognize it as an
assumption yeah you have to recognize it
as assumption and you have to be
sensitive to the first thing that you
see that tells you that the Assumption
might be weaker than you think right so
exactly so I do want to spend a little
more time here because there's a lot of
value to be had yeah one thing so if we
can step over into bat tent land
bats make sense they're a bunch of
different species several different
evolutions
why they do it is has been a mystery and
it was a mystery that I focused on uh
for graduate work
that males make tense is a fairly safe
assumption many people assume only males
make tense all the evidence I've seen is
consistent with that why is it a safe
assumption that males make sense because
the behavior of of bats around tense is
often consistent with uh
arm defense polygyny in which the tent
is an attractant it's a so unless these
are sexual reversed species uh the males
tents appear to be a resource that is
defensible by males and therefore why
wouldn't males be defending them and we
see males defending them on the other
hand they could be defending something
they didn't make but then right but then
the point is the females are making them
that it's not a very good attractant for
females if females are safe well unless
they're making them and then being
having them stolen by the males
yeah let's put it this way you end up
with a very complex story when the
various cycle so do males make tents
sure seems like it everything and I now
know for sure that they do because I've
watched it happen but that does not mean
the number of times tents have been
observed in construction is exactly two
and they're both me and uh I only saw a
fraction of a construction in one case
and a complete construction are nearly
complete in the other both males but
that's far from enough evidence to say
females never do this right and in fact
the animals in question are never found
outside of a tents or are there
circumstances in which a female doesn't
have a tent available and we never see
them Roost anywhere else so uh so anyway
I mean it's a little like you know in a
culture where men are the builders and
you know maybe it's a it's a
hunter-gatherer culture and they don't
have a permanent settlement and one of
the things you do when you move to a new
settlement is you know as as you land a
new place is like you know the the Men
start sourcing materials to build to
build places to shelter and the women
start sourcing uh you know firewood to
build fires to start cooking but all the
Menards
sick or gone or I don't know what on
their phones
[Laughter]
the women if shelter needs to happen the
women are going to do this and we we
write about this uh so
this is it seems for our field but like
we write about this with regard to the
um the Pueblo people uh and the the rich
and long history of pottery making where
in modern times it's entirely a female
activity or nearly entirely a female
activity and it was assumed for a long
time that therefore ceramicists in among
the Pueblo people had always been female
but in the Chaco Canyon uh they're right
into the Four Corners they're in the
southwest uh there is evidence that
during a time of High
um
population growth men got brought into
the activity like they needed a lot more
Pottery because there were a lot more
people and Men joined The Fray so you
know this humans are going to be much
more labile around these sorts of
division of labor things uh than bats
for instance but if you never find
dayrus of bats of these bats that aren't
intense and you have females that do
exist absent males because they're
different individuals why would you
expect that females don't or can't yeah
right so uh when I two things one in
cultures that are pre-phone what men do
is they grab a banana and they say get
me Washington and then they laugh like
crazy so it's still I mean if they're in
Burkina Faso they say get me wagadugu
get me wagaduga which is actually even
funnier because just on its own it's
hilarious yeah um not the place I don't
know I've been with somebody you know my
my first
um field assistant in Madagascar was the
daughter of the UN resident
representative in Madagascar at the time
and had been she had she was British by
birth but had grown up in um in
Swaziland in Kenya I think now in
Madagascar but also they've done a
Stanton Burkina Faso and she'd lived in
wagadugu which is why I like to bring
that up yeah we're in wagaduga I see
yeah you just you say it yeah you can't
help but be happy so that was a
distraction that was okay the other
point I wanted to make I want to show
this is such a good question how you do
this yeah testing thing I want to give
you two little examples I'll try to try
and do them fast
one why do bats make tents okay there
were all kinds of hypotheses it provides
shelter from rain these are wet habitats
it uh provides concealment from uh
predatory creatures that can't see it
yada yada
um the hypothesis that I tested which
was new I generated it was
that because all the bats that do this
tent making thing are small and small
bats pay a high price to fly per unit of
distance
and because these are all frugivores
and because fruit where fruit is
available is not a fixed location it's
not like you're feeding on insects that
are always over a water a pond or
something you're feeding on fruit and
this part of the forest fruits now and
then two weeks later it'll be you know a
kilometer that way
so the hypothesis was for lots of
reasons lots of features of the pattern
suggested something like this that the
bats create tents near the currently
active fruit source and then they return
the following year when that food source
becomes active again sometimes they
reinhabit the same tense and that this
is a limiting it limits commuting costs
right now that uh the way to test that
hypothesis was
catch bats not intense catch them glue
transmitters to them
and then see whether or not they are in
fact commuting from a tent shave a
little piece of them and then glue
transmitters to their bare skin yes
which is a it's a terrible method these
are small bats the transmitters while
tiny aren't uh
so terribly tiny they fall off because
you've glued them on and it's dicey
you're gluing them onto a you know a
creature with oil on its skin and things
like this and the transmitters are so
tiny that they're very weak so picking
up a signal involves running around the
forest all day trying to hear the
dimmest thing that lasts for like less
than two weeks yeah so anyway it's a
it's a very annoying technique but
nonetheless what we did find out in you
know a unfortunately small number of
animals was that the animals always
roosted very close to the trees where
they foraged
um and it was a completely unviolated
pattern so anyway that suggests that
this is a at least a primary motivator
and probably the reason that this
pattern keeps evolving in small fruit
bats doesn't mean that the bats don't
protect from rain it doesn't mean that
the tents don't protect from rain or
don't protect from predators but the
idea that what motivates the
construction of each individual tent is
the moving of the fruiting tree is
significant now here's the subsidiary
thing in looking at this
I noticed that on the list of animals
that make tense there was one animal
that violated a couple different
patterns one it was bigger than all of
the other temp makers and two it did not
have a uh
in each location it did not have a
particular architecture that it was
known for right it was eclectic in a way
that none of the others were and so okay
what is that pattern about hypothesis
it's not a Tent Maker it's a tent
stealer that it's opportunistically
using tents made by other animals and
the test for this actually
was to go back through the list of all
of the tent makers which have been
collected by another author who did a
survey of all that was known about tent
making and he had a chart in this chart
you could see every single time that
this bat art tibious Jimmy's census was
identified as a tent maker and the plant
that it used and the architecture that
it built was listed it was always in the
very same location another animal was
listed with that same architecture in
that same species of plant right so that
is at least a pattern consistent across
many many data sets not a maker not a
maker but a thief and so anyway that's
still not in the published literature
but I did get me to the point where I
came to understand something based on a
hypothesis test that frankly presumably
because I didn't publish that work this
still confuses other people they look at
it and they think they in explaining
tent making they have to include
explaining this species which in fact
probably isn't a tent maker yep almost
certainly isn't
in that case so you don't you don't
throw out outliers that's cheating and
uh and will often further confuse you
for exactly this reason you look to
explain to outliers and it may be that
the outliers are the key to the puzzle
so another way to say that is
um
In the comparison between signal and
noise it's important to remember that
noise is always signal for some other
pattern that's right it's a noise right
exactly it is exactly like that
um in fact it is that I know homoplasia
is noise relative to Adaptive hypotheses
so homoplasy is uh phylogenic
systematics speak for convergence or
reversals you know places where
organisms have arrived at the same but
it's actually like just not exactly the
same but a truly similar solution to
similar problems but not because they
have shared history
so you know easy things are flight in
dragonflies and birds and bats or you
know burrowing in different species uh
or
um well you know like we were talking
about yesterday carnivorous in in Plants
right like there are there are several
evolutions of carnivorean plants and
sometimes you know all the nepenthes all
those pitcher plants that we were
talking about there is separate evidence
to suggests that all of those have a
single origin of carnivoree all of those
nepenthes inherited their Carnival from
a an ancestor that was a carnivorous
plant but then you compare it to the
Venus fly trap just because that's the
famous one to name I I think that that's
a separate Evolution and so the most
recent common ancestor of those two
species was not carnivorous and
therefore you have homoplasy between
those two but that you know that then
excite you know that's the interesting
question okay why why did these
different lineages of plants all come up
with carnivorous why do these um you
know in the case of tent bats it's it's
one evolution
oh no it's uh it's at least four it's so
it's like eight or not you already said
this eight or nine architectures of ten
I think there are nine nine
architectures commonly recognized uh and
within and then each of the separate oh
right right so there's the Honduran
white bat which is a separate Evolution
and there's all the like artibians yeah
which is not how you say that
UMES and um what are the I only I only
come up with the two I mean this is part
of the old world uh
um I thought you weren't as compelled by
them as a Tent Maker uh this is deep in
the weeds yeah hey guys that was a clip
from our monthly private q a that you
can get access to at my Heather Heinz
patreon and you can also get access
there to all of the past paid subscriber
content so please consider joining us
there
did you mention that these private q and
A's are the key to living a better life
and living to tell the tale I forgot to
do that these private q and A's are in
fact the key to living a better life and
what living to tell the tale living to
tell the tale go ahead Live to Tell the
tale join us there see ya